l'isie annoncé la formation d'un nouveau
gouvernement dans un communiqué la
présidence a indiqué avoir approuvé ses
membres une semaine après le limogeage
du précédent cabinet par le président
henri sayyed ce dernier s'est approprié
les pleins pouvoirs en juillet dernier
depuis le parlement tunisien est
suspendu de toutes ces activités une
atteinte à l'état de droit sur
nombreuses associations et plusieurs
partis de l'opposition
et pour en parler en juin tout de suite
notre reporter bassem chez bien en
direct de tunis
bassem bonjour alors après de longs mois
d'attenté nouveau gouvernement est
enfants formés en tunisie
bonjour me naoui fait effectivement il
aura fallu attendre 11 semaines pour
voir enfin un nouveau gouvernement en
tunisie après l'éviction souvenez vous
le 25 juillet dernier de l'ancien
cabinet d'hichem mais ici il ya environ
une trentaine de minutes près la
république a terminé son discours qui a
été diffusé en direct à la télévision
nationale un discours qui a clôturé
cette cérémonie de nomination du nouveau
gouvernement de najlae bouden est la
chef du gouvernement a alterné que la
lutte contre la corruption sera le plus
important objectif de son gouvernement
qui compte 26 membres avec najlae bouden
celle d'hommes neufs pas me constituer
ce nouveau cabinet samir saïd un
banquier a été nommé ministre de
l'économie et de la planification et
l'avocate a aussi que kraft est le digne
héritier du portefeuille de l'intérieur
dont il était déjà titulaire entre 70
2020 et janvier 2021 d'après un bref
discours devant sa nouvelle équipe et
devant le président de sayyed que najlae
bouden a laissé place à la tribu de
serment des nouveaux ministres qui se
sont présentés devant le président une
main sur le coran afin de jurer servir
le pays et la constitution juste après
on a eu un discours d'une trentaine de
minutes du président kaïs sayed qui est
revenu sur les raisons d'un coup de
force du 25 juillet dernier et sur la
nomination de ce nouveau gouvernement il
a déclaré que c'était un jour historique
pour la tunisie il a commencé ce
discours en remerciant en neige la boue
gêne d'avoir accepté cette lourde aux
responsabilités en cette période de
crise il a aussi annoncé que c'était un
honneur pour les tunisiens que madame
najlae bouden sur la première femme d'un
gouvernement tunisien ait un
gouvernement arabe que c'était un
message pour les femmes tunisiennes qui
doivent demeurer toujours active le
président de la république a insisté sur
la situation en tunisie
il a annoncé qu'ils allaient qui
souhaitaient sauver le pays contre ses
détracteurs en tunisie comme à
l'étranger il a dit que nous allons
ouvrir tous les dossiers car il n'y a
pas de place pour ceux qui veulent
porter atteinte à l'état nous passerons
du désespoir à l'espoir les mots j'ai
été fort bien le préciser est maîtrisée
devant un parterre de nouveaux ministres
il a déclaré concernant plusieurs
critiques qu'il a essuyées depuis son
coup de force du 25 juillet dernier avec
une et qui ne marchaient pas dans le
brouillard qu'il était dans une bataille
de libération de son pays et qui gagnera
grâce à l'aide de dieu il est revenu un
petit peu sur le parlement ce parlement
qui est fermé et jolie depuis le 25
juillet dernier au lignite et des
parlementaires a été levée ainsi que
leur salaire il n'a pas hésité à montrer
quelques photos une dizaine de photos du
parlement devant ses nouveaux ministres
elle des photos sur lesquelles on
pouvait voir plusieurs beaucoup de
violence des altercations entre députés
un député mmm on sent beaucoup de mal
elle dans ce dans ce parlement tunisien
et il a annoncé en montrant ses poteaux
que ces images étaient choquantes était
grave et indigne de la tunisie voilà la
raison pour laquelle il a dû fermer ce
parlement ce parlement qui étaient
encore fermés en attend peut-être les
futurs d'élections législatives en
tunisie pour que tout l'appareil
institutionnelle et démocratique et
puisse redémarrer surtout après l
annonce de ce nouvel nouveau
gouvernement dans cette tunisie qui
connaît une crise déjà majeur politique
économique et sociale depuis plusieurs
mois merci madame chebi je rappelle que
vous êtes notre correspondant à tunis